tenemos a fx es igual a 4x a la quinta
menos 3x al cuadrado más 3 todo esto
sobre 6x a la quinta menos 100 x al
cuadrado menos 10 ahora yo quiero pensar
en cuál es el límite el límite de fx
mientras x se aproxima a infinito y hay
varias maneras de hacer esto puede
sustituir números muy grandes más y más
grandes cada vez y así ver si esto se
aproxima a un valor o podemos razonar lo
a lo que me refiero es ver el
comportamiento del numerador y
denominador mientras x se hace muy muy
muy grande y lo que yo digo es que
mientras x se hace muy grande hay que
enfocarnos ahorita en el numerador
mientras se que se hace muy grande este
término en el numerador 4x a la quinta
será mucho más significante que
cualquiera de estos algo al cuadrado se
hace grande pero algo elevado a la
quinta crece mucho más rápido
similarmente en el denominador este
término el término con el grado mayor 6x
a la quinta
crecerá más rápido que cualquiera de los
otros términos aún más que este que bien
tiene coeficientes 100 bueno va a crecer
más rápido que ese no importa el 100
cuando tomamos algo cuando tienes algo
elevado a la quinta crecerá mucho más
rápido que algo elevado al cuadrado
entonces mientras x se hace muy muy
grande esto se va a aproximar a 4x a la
quinta sobre 6x a la quinta para x muy
grande o puedes decir que mientras x se
aproxima a infinito mientras x se
aproxima a infinito
ahora bien podemos simplificar esto
claro porque tenemos x a la quinta sobre
x a la quinta estos dos se cancelan y
nos quedan entonces dos tercios dos
tercios podríamos decir que el límite de
fx mientras x se aproxima a infinito
mientras x se hace más más grande todos
esos términos no van a importar tanto
entonces esto se aproximará a dos
tercios
veamos la gráfica vale veamos y si tiene
sentido lo que estamos diciendo estamos
diciendo que hay unas tinto está
horizontal en dos tercios y aquí está la
gráfica la obtuve de wolframalpha esta
línea da poco nombre entonces bueno
vemos que x en efecto mientras x crece
fx parecerá aproximarse a este valor que
al parecer es de dos tercios entonces
aquí voy a dibujar una 5ta horizontal la
voy a dibujar un poco mejor ok entonces
tenemos una cinta horizontal justo en
dos tercios la estoy dibujando lo mejor
que puedo aquí es igual a dos tercios el
límite mientras x se hace muy grande
mientras se aproxima a infinito que se
acerca cada vez más a dos tercios pero
si solamente observamos la gráfica
parece que lo mismo está pasando desde
la dirección de abajo mientras x se
aproxima a menos infinito entonces
podríamos decir que el límite de fx
mientras x se aproxima a menos infinito
eso también parece ser dos tercios
podemos de hecho usar la misma
cuando x se hace un número muy negativo
se aleja o se va cada vez más a la
izquierda en la línea numérica entonces
los únicos números que van a interesar
son el 4x a la quinta y el 6 x a la
quinta así que esto es verdad para x muy
grande y es también verdad para x muy
negativa entonces también podemos decir
que mientras x se aproxima a menos
infinito y el x a la quinta sobre x a la
quinta se cancelan obtenemos nuevamente
dos tercios una vez más tú lo puedes ver
en la gráfica
tenemos una a sin tota horizontal en de
igual a dos tercios el límite cuando f x
tiende a infinito eso es dos tercios y
el límite cuando f de x tiende a menos
infinito es también dos tercios cuando
tú hagas esto debes pensar en qué
términos
dominarán al resto y enfocarte en esos
nos vemos